les comptes de la sécurité sociale nous
ont habitués à leur énorme dents-de-scie
semblable au sommet et au valais de
l'himalaya chaque année on y voit valser
les milliards dans tous les sens
la dernière température l'an dernier en
79 du grand malade qu'est la sécurité
sociale était présentée comme quasiment
mortel un déficit de près de 11
milliards et la perspective d'un trou de
22 milliards cette année
c'est alors qu'on a décidé le remède de
cheval dans tous les domaines des
dépenses de santé
un remède portant sur les économies et
sur les augmentations de cotisations
un remède qui maintenant donne la fièvre
médecins et aux syndicats et voilà ce
qui apparaît aujourd'hui sur la feuille
de température non seulement le déficit
de la sécurité sociale a miraculeusement
disparu mais on prévoit un excédent de
plus de 8 milliards pour cette année
tout cela mérite explication bien sûr
bernard chevallier en juillet 1979 le
gouvernement décide un plan de
redressement de la sécurité sociale
parmi les mesures retenues il faut noter
le relèvement temporaire à compter du
1er août 1 % de la cotisation des
salariés un versement exceptionnel de
l'état une connaissance plus rapide de
l'état des comptes une amélioration
aussi de la gestion
et puis à l'effort demandé aux français
pour réduire leurs dépenses de santé
aujourd'hui la commission des comptes de
la sécurité sociale a donc pris
connaissance des premiers résultats
c'est vous le voyez un rapport consiste
en une ce n'est qu'un rapport technique
qui permet aux responsables du ministère
d'affirmer que la sécurité sociale est
entré dans la voie du redressement
alors j'ai demandé au ministre jacques
barrot s'il n'y avait pas une
contradiction entre cette efforts
demandés aux salariés et ce bénéfice de
7 milliards 500 millions de francs qui
apporter de l'argent frais dans les
caisses
non mais faut se rappeler qu'en 1978
nous avions un déficit de 10 milliards
et que 1979 prenait le même chemin avec
des perspectives de déficit aussi
important même plus
alors on a demandé un effort
exceptionnel ce point de cotisation
supplémentaire qui a été demandé aux
assurés sociaux
avec ça je dois dire qu'on à combler les
déficits etc l'année 1980 va se terminer
en équilibre pour la sécurité sociale
mais ce qui est le plus intéressant est
ce qui est nouveau c'est que le n'a
commencé grâce aux efforts des français
pour ne pas gaspiller pour ne pas abuser
de la sécurité sociale à mieux maîtriser
la dépense et c'est pourquoi je pense
que l' équilibre durable la cité sociale
et maintenant disons à notre portée tout
n'est pas fini si en 1981 et bien
effectivement il n'y aura plus l'accès
la cotisation exceptionnelle
il est certain qu'il y aura encore un
risque de déficit d'un déficit plus
modérée qui peut encore être résorbé
mais tout cela veut dire qu'il faut être
persévérant dans les efforts que nous
avons commencé